est sortie sur le balcon de sa maison
avec sa fille, qu'elle élevait en tant que mère célibataire,
à l'annonce de sa victoire.
(Applaudissements)
Cette femme a été un modèle incroyable
pour moi et pour tous ceux de ma génération,
y compris les garçons.
Elle raconte souvent cette anecdote : un jeune garçon,
après ses deux premiers mandats,
lui a demandé : « C'est vrai que les garçons peuvent devenir président ? »
(Rires)
Avoir des modèles d'identification est important,
mais même avec des modèles si forts,
dont je suis si reconnaissante,
quand on m'a poussée à être candidate à la présidence,
je me suis d'abord dit : « Qui suis-je pour vouloir être présidente ?
Qui suis-je pour être présidente? »
Il s'avère que les femmes
envisagent moins leur candidature que les hommes.
Une étude menée aux États-Unis en 2011
a montré que 62% des hommes ont envisagé d'être candidats
contre 45% des femmes.
C'est une différence de 16%.
C'est la même différence qui existait dix ans avant.
C'est vraiment dommage
parce que je suis convaincue que le monde a grand besoin de dirigeantes
et d'un leadership qui a plus de principes,
de manière générale.
Au final, ma décision d'être candidate
est venue du fait
que je pensais
que je devais aider comme je pouvais,
même sans expérience en politique,
que je devais m'efforcer de contribuer à créer un monde
qui ait du sens et qui soit viable sur le long terme
pour nos enfants ;
un monde où nous autorisons vraiment nos filles et nos garçons
à réussir à atteindre leur potentiel.
C'était la plus belle aventure de ma vie.
C'était formidable.
Cette aventure a commencé avec potentiellement 20 candidats.
Ce nombre s'est réduit à neuf candidats qualifiés
et finalement il y a eu quatre candidats à l'élection :
trois hommes et moi.
(Applaudissements)
Mais il y a eu d'autres coups de théâtre.
Vous croyez que les États-Unis sont maîtres de cela,
mais je peux...
(Rires)
Je peux vous assurer que nous avons nos propres péripéties en Islande.
Notre Président, qui occupe son poste depuis vingt ans,
a d'abord annoncé qu'il ne se représenterait pas.
C'est sans doute ce qui explique
la multiplication des candidatures.
Plus tard, il a changé d'avis
quand notre Premier Ministre a démissionné
à la suite du scandale des « Panama papers »
auquel lui et sa famille sont mêlés.
Le peuple islandais protestait,
alors le président en exercice
s'est dit qu'il leur fallait un dirigeant de confiance.
Quelques jours plus tard, des liens avec sa femme et sa belle-famille
ont été découverts dans les Panama papers.
Il s'est donc à nouveau retiré de la course.
Avant de se retirer, il a déclaré qu'il se retirait
parce qu'il y avait désormais deux hommes qualifiés dans la course
qui avaient les épaules pour occuper son poste.
Alors, le 9 mai, à 45 jours de l'élection,
le vent ne paraissait pas en ma faveur.
Je n'apparaissais même pas sur le graphique dans le journal.
Les sondages disaient que j'avais 1% d'intentions de vote.
C'était quand même supérieur
au score de toute autre femme ayant annoncé sa candidature.
Le moins qu'on puisse dire, c'est que j'ai dû travailler d'arrache-pied
pour avoir le droit de participer au débat
et pour avoir accès à la télévision,
parce que les chaînes de télévision ont décidé
que seuls les candidats qui auraient 2,5% dans les sondages
participeraient au premier débat télévisé.
J'ai appris l'après-midi même du débat
que j'allais y participer avec les trois hommes
et j'ai découvert en direct à la télévision
que j'avais obtenu précisément 2,5% le jour du débat.
(Applaudissements)
Parlons des difficultés qui se sont présentées.
Les plus grandes difficultés à surmonter durant cette aventure
ont été liées aux média, au pouvoir d'appareil et à l'argent.
Commençons par les médias.
Certains disent que le genre importe peu
dans les médias et en politique.
Je ne suis pas d'accord.
Il a été plus difficile pour moi d'accéder aux médias et avoir de l'antenne.
En vérité, les candidats en tête ont été présents dans des émissions
87 fois dans les mois précédant l'élection,
et moi seulement 31 fois.
Je ne dis pas que les médias sont conscients de ce qu'ils font.
C'est dû en grande partie à des préjugés inconscients, je crois.
Les médias, comme tout le monde,
ont des préjugés conscients et inconscients.
Nous devons avoir le courage d'en parler pour que ça change.
Quand j'ai enfin eu accès à la télévision,
voici la première question que j'ai eue : « Allez-vous abandonner ? »
C'était difficile de répondre.
Comme j'avais 1 ou 2,5% dans les sondages,
ça se comprend peut-être.
Les médias ont vraiment de l'influence et à chacune de mes apparitions,
je montais dans les sondages.
Je suis bien placée pour savoir combien c'est important
et pourquoi il faut en parler.
Je suis la seule des quatre candidats en lice
qui n'a pas eu d'interview à la une des journaux.
Parfois, on ne me laissait pas répondre à des questions posées aux trois autres.
Ou bien les médias ne parlaient pas de moi.
J'ai dû faire face à ça,
mais je dirais une chose en faveur des médias islandais,
ils n'ont pas vraiment commenté ma coiffure et mon tailleur.
(Applaudissements)
Un bon point pour eux.
Une autre dimension de mon expérience est importante.
J'étais une candidate indépendante,
sans appareil de parti derrière moi.
Mon manque d'expérience
et de ressources
a probablement nuit à notre campagne
mais nous a aussi aidés à innover et à faire de la politique différemment.
Nous avons mené une campagne positive
et nous avons ainsi sans doute fait changer le ton des élections.
Peut-être que j'ai eu moins de temps de parole
parce que je montrais à mes opposants que je les respectais.
Quand accéder aux médias s'est avéré si difficile,
nous avons organisé nos propres médias.
Des sessions en direct sur Facebook
m'ont permis de répondre sur le vif à des électeurs sur tous les sujets.
Nous avons mis toutes ces questions et réponses en libre accès sur Facebook
parce que ne rien cacher est important
pour établir une relation de confiance.
Quand il s'est avéré difficile d'avoir accès aux jeunes électeurs,
je me suis mise à Snapchat.
J'ai demandé à des jeunes de m'apprendre,
j'ai utilisé tous les filtres de Snapchat vers la fin de la campagne.
J'ai dû faire preuve d'humour et d'humilité parce que j'étais nulle.
Grâce à ça, davantage de jeunes ont suivi notre campagne.
Il est donc possible d'avoir une campagne électorale différente.
Malheureusement, qui dit politique dit argent.
C'est triste, mais c'est comme ça,
et nous avions moins de ressources financières que les autres candidats.
Je pense que c'est dû en partie au fait
que c'était plus difficile pour moi de demander du soutien.
Peut-être aussi que je voulais être économe,
comme le sont les femmes, dira-t-on.
Mais même avec un tiers des médias, un tiers de l'argent
et seulement une équipe hors du système, mais géniale,
nous avons réussi à surprendre tout le monde le soir des élections
à l'annonce des premiers résultats.
J'ai été surprise moi-même ; voyez cette photo.
(Rires)
Selon les premiers résultats,
j'étais au coude-à-coude avec le candidat en tête.
(Acclamations)
C'était un peu trop tôt. Je n'ai pas eu ce résultat,
mais je suis arrivée deuxième.
Nous avons explosé les estimations à 1%
avec près d'un tiers des voix.
Nous avons fait mentir les sondages comme jamais,
avec une marge de 10 points de plus que les dernières estimations.
Certains disent que je suis donc la vraie gagnante
et beaucoup m'ont encouragé à me représenter.
Ce qui me rend vraiment fière,
c'est de savoir que j'ai récolté
la plus grande proportion du vote des jeunes
et beaucoup de gens ont encouragé ma fille à se présenter en 2040.
(Applaudissements)
Elle a 13 ans
et n'était jamais passée à la télévision avant.
Et le jour des élections, je l'ai bien observée.
Elle était intelligente, elle était sûre d'elle,
elle était sincère et elle soutenait sa maman.
C'était sans doute ça, le meilleur moment de ma campagne.
(Applaudissements)
Voici un autre temps fort.
Ces petites filles en promenade avec leur maternelle
ont vu une de mes affiches sur un abribus
et ont ressenti le besoin de l'embrasser.
(Public : Oh !)
Cette photo était déjà une victoire pour moi.
On peut devenir ce que l'on voit.
Envoyons paître peur et difficultés.
(Applaudissements)
Il importe que des femmes soient candidates
et il est grand temps qu'elles se présentent aux élections,
que ce soit au poste de PDG ou à la présidence.
J'ai même fait forte impression sur votre « New Yorker ».
Ils m'ont décerné ce nouveau titre : « un émoticône de sincérité vivant ».
(Acclamations)
C'est peut-être le titre dont je suis le plus fière
parce que les femmes sont trop souvent pénalisées
parce qu'elles utilisent ce que j'appelle leur capital émotionnel,
alors que je sais d'expérience qu'il est si bénéfique
de s'en servir.
(Applaudissements)
C'est ce dont nous avons besoin, de plus en plus.
Le soir de l'élection, nous avons fait la fête comme si nous avions gagné
parce que c'était comme si.
Il ne s'agit pas forcément d'accéder au poste.
Il s'agit de se lancer.
Si vous, votre famille, vos amis et toute votre équipe
vous y prenez bien, vous apprendrez plus que jamais dans votre vie.
Nous avons apprécié cette expérience
et j'ai beaucoup appris ;
beaucoup plus que je ne peux dire ici
dans le peu de temps que nous avons.
Mais ne vous méprenez pas : c'était du travail.
J'ai perdu beaucoup d'heures de sommeil pendant la campagne.
J'ai dû résister et persévérer pour ne pas abandonner
mais j'ai appris quelque chose que je savais déjà,
c'est que pour exceller,
il faut écouter attentivement sa voix intérieure
et lui rester authentiquement fidèle.
Une des mes sœurs dit souvent
que vous pouvez trahir votre intuition
mais votre intuition ne vous trahira jamais.
Je pense aussi que ce qui est important, et vous le savez tous,
dans toute aventure,
c'est l'équipe qu'on choisit.
C'est d'être entouré de gens qui ont les mêmes valeurs et la même vision,
mais sont complètement différents.
C'est la recette du succès selon moi,
et j'ai la chance d'avoir un mari formidable,
qui est ici,
et une famille formidable,
(Applaudissements)
et des super amis.
Nous sommes entrés en politique ensemble en indépendants
et avons réussi ce que beaucoup décrivaient comme impossible.
En fait, le plus grand expert en relations publiques m'a dit,
avant que je me décide,
que j'aurais de la chance si j'obtenais 7%.
J'ai apprécié son point de vue : il avait sans doute raison
et il s'appuyait sur sa grande expérience.
Mais les sondages à 1%
m'ont décidé à lui montrer qu'il avait tort.
Il est important de mentionner ceci, parce que j'ai vraiment peu dormi,
et j'ai travaillé dur, tout comme mon équipe :
on ne peut pas tenir la distance si on oublie de prendre soin de soi.
Voilà deux choses très importantes.
Il faut s'entourer de personnes et de méthodes qui sont bénéfiques,
mais il est aussi important, et peut-être même plus,
d'avoir le courage de se débarrasser des gens et des méthodes
qui épuisent votre énergie,
y compris ces commentateurs et bloggers formidables.
J'ai eu beaucoup de soutien en ce sens
et j'ai décidé de ne pas me rabaisser quand d'autres se rabaissaient,
et c'est en partie comme ça que j'ai conservé mon énergie.
Et quand j'avais un coup de fatigue,
ce qui arrivait parfois, ce n'était pas facile,
alors je me rappelais pourquoi j'étais candidate
et que j'avais décidé de faire campagne à ma façon.
J'ai appelé ça une campagne 4G.
Chaque G représente un mot islandais.
D'abord, il y a « Gagn ».
J'étais candidate pour faire le bien,
pour servir mon pays.
La notion d'un leadership au service du pays
devait être au centre de notre travail pour ma campagne.
Il y a ensuite « Gleði », la joie.
J'ai décidé d'apprécier l'aventure.
Il y avait beaucoup à en apprendre
qu'on arrive à gagner ou non.
J'ai fait de mon mieux pour encourager les autres à faire pareil.
Le troisième mot est « Gagnsæi ».
J'étais ouverte à toute question.
Je n'avais pas de secret,
et tout était transparent, sur Facebook et sur d'autres sites.
Je pense que si vous décidez qui élire président,
vos questions méritent des réponses.
Le dernier principe, et pas des moindres,
je n'ai pas besoin d'expliquer ça à ce public,
était le principe du « Girl Power », le pouvoir des femmes.
(Acclamations)
Je suis vraiment contente
d'avoir eu le courage d'être candidate,
d'avoir pris le risque d'échouer, mais d'avoir eu du succès
de bien des façons.
Il serait faux de dire que ça a été facile,
mais ce que je peux vous assurer,
et je pense que mon équipe sera d'accord avec moi,
c'est que ça en valait vraiment la peine.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Pat Mitchell : Ne partez pas si vite.
Halla Tómasdóttir : Quel public !
PM : Ne vous laissons pas partir sans dire
que tout le monde ici voudrait sûrement s'installer en Islande
et voter pour vous.
Bon, nous ne pouvons sûrement pas voter,
mais une chose qu'on peut trouver en Islande,
et que j'y trouve toujours, c'est de l'inspiration.
A mon âge, je me souviens de 1975
et de la grève des Islandaises.
Elle a fortement contribué à lancer le mouvement pour les droits des femmes.
Vous y avez fait référence tout à l'heure. Revoyons la photo.
Souvenons-nous de cette occasion où le pays s'est retrouvé à l'arrêt.
Ce que vous ignorez peut-être
parce que nos médias américains n'en ont rien dit,
c'est que les Islandaises ont de nouveau fait grève lundi, n'est-ce pas ?
HT : Oui, c'est vrai. PM : Dites-en nous quelques mots.
HT : 41 ans après la grève initiale,
même si nous sommes le meilleur pays du monde pour les femmes,
il reste encore du travail à faire.
Alors, lundi à 14h38,
les Islandaises ont quitté leur travail
parce qu'elles avaient gagné leur salaire journalier.
(Applaudissements)
Ce qui était cool,
c'est que des jeunes femmes, des jeunes hommes ont participé à la grève
en plus grand nombre que jamais
parce qu'il est temps que les salaires soient égaux.
PM : Je ne vais pas forcer Halla à révéler
ses projets
mais j'ajoute que vous auriez une armée de bénévoles
si vous décidiez de vous présenter de nouveau.
Merci, Halla.
HT : Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)